[Musique]
cette séance de yoga xxl va permettre de
sauver trois enfants atteints de
problèmes au coeur dans les pays en
développement
baptisé les yogis du coeur l'événement
était organisé ce dimanche 24 septembre
par l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque à l'orangerie du château de
versailles objectifs de la structure
récolter des dons grâce à une action
sportive
je pense que pour un sportif c'est
plaisant de se dire je m'adonne un
exercice à une action qui me plaît et en
même temps ça va profiter à d'autres
comme on dit aujourd'hui c'est gagnant
gagnant
la séance d'une heure et demie a réuni
près de 700 adultes et une centaine
d'enfants tous et yogi ont versé 25
euros de frais d'inscription
peu importe la séance et on vient pas
tant pour faire le yoga plus pour
partager ce moment et est
sponsorisé le mécénat du coeur oui c'est
un rendez vous important parce que c'est
un moment de partage et qu'on sait que
c'est pour la bonne cause et dans un
lieu extraordinaire
d'autres yogi du coeur seront organisées
dans les grandes villes françaises le
prochain rendez-vous en ile-de-france
est programmée le 17 décembre prochain
au palais des congrès de paris